wake the [ __ ] up
samurai we have a city to burn
in the 1990s the central american wars
were started by a new corrupt
and manipulative government known as the
gang of four
an organization consisting of the nsa
cia
fbi and dea at a time when natural and
political disasters were ripe
the us government made a number of poor
decisions that impacted the country's
stock market
and in turn the world economy
headed by the cia the gang of four
successfully infiltrated the american
government
with the world economy and tatters they
managed to convince congress that this
conflict was a fight against the drugs
that were entering the united states
however in reality they were using this
opportunity to expand their influence
and use american troops to put a stop to
the south american political enemies of
the cia
it was also during this time that a new
industry was starting to gain momentum
cybernetics the government used the
chaos that was unfolding around the
country
as an opportunity to test this new
technology on the dismembered
and maimed soldiers and this is where we
are introduced to a young man
by the name of robert john under who
enlisted into the u.s military to do his
part in fighting for his country
nevertheless over time the government's
secrets were uncovered
and many of the american soldiers
dropped their weapons and deserted
johnny was among these soldiers he
refused to fight in a corrupt war
so the government hit back purposefully
swaying the public's opinion
and encouraging hostility and violence
towards the deserters
but regardless johnny decided it was
time to go back home and start over
so he changed his name to johnny
silverhand in reference to a cybernetic
arm
that he received after losing the limb
in battle
the war had changed him it had opened
his eyes to what was
really happening so johnny made it his
mission to enlighten the people of the
corruption and lies of the government
back in night city johnny formed the
chrome rock band
known as samurai originally they were
only featured in small clubs throughout
the city
but it wasn't long before they were
approached by jack masters the head of
universal music
he signed them up and within weeks
samurai had risen to the top of the
charts
their music was revolutionary and
quickly gained notoriety
sparking tours in major cities worldwide
but it wouldn't last forever their
keyboard player
nancy was in an abusive relationship and
eventually it became too much for her
so she pushed her partner out of their
apartment window on the 83rd story
although she went to prison the band
fully supported nancy
but in spite of this the time while she
was locked up made them realize that
they were all heading in different
directions
and samurai split up in 2008
although johnny silverhand was one of
the most popular musicians around
he was yet to make it to the height of
his career he decided to go solo
and further push his anti-government
message
he was approached by many record levels
including dbs music
who was so desperate for him to sign
with them that they threatened to expose
his past
and highlight that he was a deserter
[Applause]
refusing to be their puppet he ignored
their feeble attempts at blackmail
and instead signed with universal music
his first album as a solo artist sins of
your brothers
revealed the horrific actions that the
government had taken leading up to
and during the war along with the
admission that he himself was in fact
a deserter not only was the album highly
successful
but it changed the public's perception
of the deserters throughout that time in
history
in 2013 while johnny was on a walk with
his girlfriend
alt cunningham a programmer with a gold
cybernetic arm
they were suddenly attacked by a group
of men
during the altercation he was injured
and they managed to kidnap
alt eventually he learned that these men
were working for the mega corporation
arasaka alt was a talented programmer
and was behind a program called soul
killer
and arasaka wanted her to work for them
so like all mega enterprises
if they wanted something they just took
it
[Music]
soul killer is a program capable of
creating a digital copy of a person's
mind
and storing it in a huge database it
could effectively allow the user to
download someone's brain
the body is then left as an empty shell
which will eventually die
if the original or a new mind isn't
reintroduced
[Music]
because of the complexity of the process
there are a few mainframes in the world
that are capable of running such a
program
one of which being at arasaka tower in
night city
without prior knowledge and what soul
killer was johnny made a plan to rescue
alt from arasaka
as a security mega corporation the
complex itself is one of the most secure
buildings in night city
which means he needed the right people
for the job
[Music]
hiring a team to infiltrate the offices
was only one part of the plan
johnny also needed to come up with the
perfect distraction for the arasaka's
security guards
so he crafted a scheme and enlisted the
help of his former band
samurai they would hold a reunion
concert for all of their loyal followers
and it would be right outside arasaka
tower
as expected this drew an enormous crowd
of excited and eager fans to the area
thousands upon thousands of supporters
flocked to the location
and unsurprisingly things soon got out
of hand
[Music]
samurai used their music to help
influence their frenzied fans
encouraging them to get out of control
and provoking their anger towards the
guards outside the high rise
with the concert riots operating as a
distraction johnny in the infiltration
unit
moved quickly through the complex but
unfortunately they were too late
and alt was found on the ground lifeless
cold and hollow
her mind was now trapped inside the
arasaka mainframe
following this event and given the huge
amount of damage that samurai had
brought upon the arasaka building
johnny decided to lay low for a little
while far away from night city
after some time had passed the fourth
corporate war had begun
starting relatively small it quickly
grew out of control with outside
security companies being introduced
including arasaka and militech with the
big guns coming on board
the wall was now worldwide
these security companies often hired
freelancers for covert operations
the singular most important reason being
that it's harder to trace their actions
back to a particular company
and given johnny's history with arasaka
when he was given the opportunity by
militech to join a strike team to
infiltrate arasaka tower
he was immediately on board their aim
to copy the offline database and then
destroy the cell killer labs
however unsurprisingly johnny had an
ulterior motive he was going there to
find his girlfriend
old cunningham and bring his
subconscious back from inside the
mainframe
unfortunately before he could accomplish
this he came face to face with arasaka
cyborg adam smasher
and this hired gun who was more machine
than man would ultimately prove to be
johnny's final challenge
and he was unable to survive the
encounter
whether by coincidence or pure chance
moments after the death
of johnny militech launched their attack
they dropped a bomb on the arasaka
building
which resulted in destroying any trace
of johnny's body
for decades ever since his disappearance
people have mourned johnny silverhand
and the fact that his body was never
found only fit into his legend
all over night city you can find street
art and graffiti referencing him
often with the line where's johnny
all these years later people hold on to
the hope that johnny is still out there
somewhere
planning his return to retake the reins
and pick up where he left off
fighting for the people
in cyberpunk 2077 johnny appears as v's
guide
but johnny isn't there in a physical
form he's a digital version of himself
a ghost how this happened is unknown at
this stage
all we know is that johnny shows up in
v's mine shortly after the immortality
relic was stolen
and inserted into v could it be that the
soul killer program was run on johnny
before it died
and he's been stored in this chip ever
since
jumping into such a large universe like
this is tough
i've had to heavily simplify and gloss
over events in order to stick to the
original subject of the video
there were main characters that are
barely mentioned in this and some i skip
over all together
because it would have just sent me down
a path that would have had me talking
for hours
and this is all before the game has even
been released
i see this as being an issue for a while
to come until i've managed to cover off
a larger piece of the overall history
i realize that there are probably a
number of you who know the background of
the cyberpunk story relatively in depth
and this is probably a little basic for
you but i'm trying to assist those who
are fresh
to the game starting with the basics and
building up towards the more complicated
in-depth discussions later on down the
track
there is obviously a massive amount that
i plan to run over in the coming videos
but the order at which i do this
certainly isn't set in stone so is there
anything from this video that you would
like me to cover next
like the events that led up to the
earlier wars or maybe the mega
corporations
let me know in the comments regardless
i'll be getting to them all eventually
thank you very much for watching i hope
you've enjoyed this and i'll catch in
the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
you